Earvin Magic Johnson the basketball
legend business mogul and baseball team
owner broke some news the et and he also
updated us on how Kobe Bryant's family
is doing today are y'all keeping vanessa
close and keeping an eye on those girls
and everybody and how are they doing
they're doing fine you know vanessa is
very strong magic was a mentor and close
friend to Kobe and when he saw him
Italia Brian and little sis Bianca
dancing with joy on tik-tok that was
everything and I think Kobe would have
wanted that right with them to go on
live a great life and just have enjoy
yourself and Vanessa's the reason for
that and I think she's got a great
village around or people around her to
give her that support we're hearing
rumors that a camera follow Kobe for
that final season and that may be a
documentary is that happening that's
definitely gonna happen I think he was
smart enough to have a camera follow him
document every movement what can I say
mom Bauer so we don't see a lot of
behind the scenes things on Kobe and
he'll probably let us into his world
with his family Magic has been a part of
the Michael Jordan docu-series The Last
Dance Sunday we'll finally get to see
Kobe on the show that is breaking
ratings records for ESPN I think this is
gonna be fabulous for all of us who love
Kobe Bryant and as well as we love
Michael Jordan so now we're get to see
the dynamic of their relationship play
out on the screen right and we get to
see Kobe one more time and magic gave us
a big ET exclusive first we got Michael
Jordan
then we'll have Kobe right and his dot
and then the Magic Man is coming out
with this after that that's where I'm
coming after Kobe's hey nice to hear
first nobody else knew that you got the
scoop baby you got the scoop
[Music]